Jonathan at the center is very worried
about this interview like my grooming do
I look okay what are your impressions of
Canadian so far in terms of like their
their look
well are you pressed really excited to
be back in jail and I love Montreal it's
my second time here and I yeah I just I
think Canadians are court chest and then
you flew in this morning I saw your
Jimmy to Beyonce
I did like Beyonce all it gives us all
life does it she you know how does she
do it I don't know you know she could
just like bottle that up and just give
it to everyone we could really curb
everything yes so you're just gonna go
rehearse for your gala tonight just
collapse
yes so was just blast mean to you well I
mean I think just for last is just
that's like such an essential staple
iconic like festival in the comedy space
and I'm so excited to be a part of it
and especially like hosting a gala is
like it's just such a big honor to be
chosen to do that and um and the
comedians that are gonna be here tonight
I am so inspired by all of them and I
have like new material that I'm gonna be
debuting tonight yeah I'm like I'm doing
different material than what I've been
doing on tour I'm for tonight so I like
personalized it but we're just Canada
awesome um so fingers crossed
yeah and then you're gonna be a Toronto
I guess it's six weeks for just for
laughs then yeah so will you write a new
material for Toronto too like we changed
things in that six weeks I think it
depends on its head yeah it's been how
it goes like yes right yeah he's like
whatever we'll see right yeah
now we have to talk about on Instagram
the photo with Anthony because we're
running it from his hometown yeah you
fake people out with these kissing clean
well that's our way to them well I know
that's how you celibate yeah are we
gonna get the real story now what's
happening here maybe that's about maybe
there's maybe there's a piece of it in
the fetch me that I want okay but so you
did you did do a post saying you were
just friends people were mad yeah well
she's a reaction
I don't know I don't know I just you
know when it comes to Antony I just I
like to be a little cagey you know is
everything changed you right now I don't
know you know did you know you know you
know okay okay fine now I did what type
of career I everyone was crying at the
episode where he went back to your
hometown like we didn't mean for you to
go back to her hometown of had okay
watched part of the talk with the Gay
Straight Alliance think was so powerful
to watch that so what do mean you go
back to your hometown
it was just a very moving week I think
it with if you know I graduated in 2004
when queer I the first iteration of
queer I was still on the air I think if
you'd have told me when I was 17 like on
the top three list of like
impossibilities that would be the case
when I was 32 that I would be like back
in my high school like in a second
iteration of queer I and I don't think I
would have believed you so is really
very surreal it was I
I've never been so nervous going into
yeah I that was confronting a lot of you
know memories for me and also um Kathy
Dooley someone who I really know my
whole life and I love her so much and
her that haircut was very iconic and so
I felt a lot of pressure like being the
one to like said on it's good way yeah
yeah it was really special and it was
just um it was really special that you
know production wanted to include you
know where I came from in their
narrative for the season and it was just
really special all around and that's the
thing I mean you know talking to some of
the students how much things have
changed I mean I think back I came from
a small town too and I think you know
the idea of coming out was just a crazy
concept to meet you in high school but
it's so much more accepted I mean
obviously we have we have a long way to
go still and it was a representation do
you but do you think things have changed
a lot for kids in the last I guess
probably decade or so 15 years do you
think it's changed oh I think it depends
100% on where you are right
geographically um I think that in some
ways like in Quincy for instance I think
that it has made some progress because
like they do have a Gay Straight
Alliance now which is something they did
not have when I was there and I spent
some time in Iowa in the last two years
they're like the annual like Governors
Ball so I got to see it's an LGBTQ
Governor's Ball which was pretty
cool and if they're all like the Iowa
State like high school students and that
was really incredible to see like it
started with like 50 students here now
it has like 1500 and that was like last
year or so I do think that there is like
acceptance it is you know slowly growing
but I do think that a lot of that
acceptance and a lot of the progress
that worse that we have been reaping the
benefits of was from really hard fought
work that hasn't actually been decades
in the making
and I think that when you have a
president like Donald Trump who is like
constantly you know really spewing so
much hate-filled rhetoric and on people
that are sensitive enough and empathetic
enough to understand that you know for
him it's like all a joke and and for
kids you know who are paying the price
of this bullying you know I think hate
crimes have been steadily raising for
the last few years it's the first two
years in a row where hate crimes have
actually gone up in the United States so
and I think that across the world we're
seeing that so I do think it's gotten
better but I also think that we are all
really too quickly at least from my
perspective too quick to congratulate
ourselves on where we've come yes the
long yeah I think that there's actually
like emergency is you know everywhere
yeah so I think that we have to focus on
the emergencies as it be grateful for
how far we've come but also you know it
we it's hats off to the people that have
like paved the way for us to do that I
think there are really amazing activists
doing work now but I'm like I'm really
actually a little concerned yeah and I
saw your tweet a few years ago about
your dad calling you saying support of
your parents like how important is that
that are amazing that you know they
definitely had like their own journeys
but my dad is just like I think that age
has a way of softening you know people
but especially old men and I think or
older men and so my dad is just like
such a sweet guy and he loves he loves
the boys on the class so much yeah he
really did call the day after season
four debuted and he was like crying so
hard like no noise could almost amazing
like don't have another story like
anything take deep breaths like you know
he gets really worked out my dad he's
like a stroke survivors I worry ya know
something to worry about is the Emmys
now you got another nomination for queer
I but then also your gay Thrones yeah
I feel it's a third time the camtonz has
been nominated which is really
incredible like Erin Gibson the creator
a director and I like thought of this
like so long ago and have to be
recognizing like ever nominated for an
Emmy is not anything I ever thought
would happen
oh you've won one now well yet we're not
a producer on your eyes so that once
you're actually a winner oh no no the
five of us are more nominated for hosts
we would be the nominees look actually
the five of us work here I have never
been eminent so but I have been four gay
of Thrones and I you know fingers
crossed like slurred sure but I'm also
like if it doesn't happen I'm really
comfortable
like if suit like it took Susan Lucci
like 27 years thank you and I think that
was the number and like I got to perform
on Broadway with her last year or me and
ernõ is this year and I just yeah I just
want to go to the party on it yeah it's
great to be recognized and it's like a
red carpet moment like that's okay you
know I mean yeah well now you have this
verse so yeah tonight thank you so much
now big moves awesome thank you